master class sur le col red deuxième
comme vous me l'avez demandé suite à la
première vidéo sur le col de reading
voici donc la suite dans la première on
va dire que j'abordais un petit peu la
définition et les généralités sur
comment pratiquer ou en tout cas comment
s'y préparer et dans les nombreux
commentaires et échanges qu'on a eus
ensemble à chaque fois il ya quelque
chose quand même qui revient c'est on en
fait quoi après une fois qu'on a
commencé à observer ou à déduire des
choses je vais passer en revue avec vous
une douzaine d'exemples est-ce qu'on
pourrait en retirer les poignées de
mains les fameuses poignée de main qu'on
connaît bien qu'on soit un homme ou une
femme ça nous arrive de serrer la main
la poignée de main à demain vous savez
celle où la personne nous prend la main
et la compagne avec la deuxième main
pour resserrer au niveau du poignet
vraiment au niveau de la main donc à l'
enveloppe un peu notre main c'est un
comportement tout à fait typique des
personnes qui cherchent un petit peu à
cacher leur émotion à leur intimité ou à
chercher le rapprochement un peu plus
qu'ils ne devraient surtout dans le cas
d'une poignée de main avec quelqu'un
qu'on ne connaît pas ou peu si je devais
sortir une phrase à cette personne pour
valider ce comportement là avec lui
gilles prononcerai pas ces mots là
surtout pas par contre je pourrais tout
à fait lui dire parfois vous vous sentez
très seul ou un petit peu trop seul et
je pense qu'avoir des gens autour de
vous qui vous soutiennent qu'ils sont
avec vous c'est quelque chose de très
important pour vous et là vous ferez
mouche parce que ce genre de
préoccupation est tout à fait juste pour
une personne dont vous avez détruit tel
comportement via la poignée de main dans
la même idée quelqu'un qui se fait une
grosse poignée de main ferme un petit
peu trop ferme un petit peu trop
violente sur l'échelle de la poignée de
main lui on pourrait facilement lui dire
récemment vous avez découvert qu'il ya
des gens qui se comportait pas
conformément un petit peu à vos valeurs
à vos usages et ça c'est quelque chose
qui vous a déçu puisque cette poignée de
main est typique des gens qui sont sur
la défensive ou des gens qui sont
agressifs ou des gens qui sont en colère
donc cette lecture là et liés à
l'interprétation encore une fois de
cette poignée de main un petit peu trop
ferme
d'ailleurs on pourrait penser que le
côté agressif et colère il est facile à
déduire via la poignée de mains très
franches comme sa trop forte
alors qu'elle fonctionne aussi avec la
poignée de main trop molle la poignée de
main un peu désabusé c'est en général
une colère un peu la tente un manque de
volonté les gens qui ont du mal à
s'engager dans les choses et là vous
pourriez lui dire récemment vous êtes
senti un petit peu exploité vous
ressentez d'ailleurs souvent des
émotions qui sont tout à fait
contradictoires mais par rapport à ce
qu'on a vu ensemble de la vidéo
précédente vous n'en êtes pas encore la
poignée de main
vous observez les gens voulaient
regarder marché alors on va parler un
petit peu de la démarche
et oui une démarche assurée surtout des
mouvements vifs au delà de la démarche
en elle même la manière dont il prend
son téléphone la manière dont il va
regarder quelque chose la manière dont
les personnes de sortir sans ticket de
métro
c'est forcément quelqu'un de directif
donc on pourrait même y aller un petit
peu par la flatterie vous êtes quelqu'un
d'organisé de réfléchi vous savez
vraiment analyser une situation
rapidement un homme c'est un petit peu
différent pour une femme un homme qui
fait de grandes enjambées c'est
quelqu'un qui a de l'ambition
c'est quelqu'un qui veut y arriver c'est
quelqu'un qui a l'esprit d'initiative
alors forcément si on parle à cette
personne là on peut pas lui dire vous
êtes un petit peu trop ambitieux le but
du col de reading c'est aussi de dire à
la personne ce qu'elle ressent et non ce
qu'elle est vraiment donc on pourrait
lui dire vous êtes quelqu'un de
particulièrement adaptable vous savez
quel chemin prendre et en général vous
fait confiance dans vos décisions vous
avez de bonnes qualités de perception et
ça vous le savez quelqu'un qui marche
avec les mains dans les poches mais avec
les bras un petit peu fléchi un pas
complètement enfoncé parce que ça c'est
peut-être plus simplement pour se
protéger du froid mais quelqu'un qui a
une température normale marche un petit
peu comme ça les mains dans les poches
pas forcément nonchalant on va dire une
démarche normale mais les mains un petit
peu enfoncé dans les poches
alors là aussi on peut se dire qu'est ce
qu'on fait de cette information le fait
que la personne a une attitude de
découragement qu'est ce que ça veut dire
en fait plus profondément
chez elle comment on pourrait faire un
bon reading de ça on pourrait ramener ça
simplement ou d'un point de vue sociétal
vous vous sentez un petit peu exploitées
par les exigences du monde qui vous
entoure par toutes les obligations et
tout ce qu'on attend de vous l'assurance
par contre dans la démarche d'une femme
ça se traduit un petit peu différemment
les épaules sont droites sont pas et un
peu balancé un petit peu détendu en
général il ya un mouvement aussi une
espèce d'oscillations niveau des hanches
et ça s'accompagne pas forcément d'une
rapidité comme chez l'homme vous
comprenez où je vais vous emmener pour
cette deuxième étape dans le col reading
sait vraiment où est ce qu'on peut aller
au delà de l'information convoi qui peut
parfois paraître évidente qu'est-ce
qu'on en fait ça imaginons que vous
faites passer pour envoyant un médium
c'est pas quelque chose que je vous
recommande de fermer c'est pour vous
mettre dans la situation et que
quelqu'un vienne vous parler est cette
personne là sans l'alcool en bon call
rider que vous êtes vous allez vous dire
ok la personne vient de boire un verre
récemment suivant lors de la journée
vous allez déterminer si c'est quelque
chose de
j pour tout le monde ou si c'est plus
problématique mais si on cherche à
élargir et qu'on se dit peu importe le
moment de la journée
qu'est-ce qui pourrait être commun à
toute personne qui sent l'alcool qui a
bu et là je parle bien de l'odeur de
l'alcool d'aia pas d'une marque d'alcool
spécifiques quelqu'un comme une bière il
sent la bière quelqu'un qui a trop bu
deux bières va sentir l'alcool il ya
quand même une différence
eh bien on pourrait tout à fait lui dire
je pense que vous avez une consommation
d'alcool qui est plutôt raisonnable
néanmoins vous avez été préoccupé par
votre propre consommation vous êtes déjà
récemment posé la question si c'était
exagéré ou pas d'autant plus que
quelques personnes vous en ont déjà
parlé c'est un parcours logique est tout
à fait commun aux personnes qui boivent
de l'alcool donc les informations sont
vraies pour la plupart est en tout cas
seront toujours vrai dans le temps si on
enlève le récemment on est sûr à 100%
et ça marche avec tous les signes qu'ils
soient physiques qu'ils soient
physiologique quelqu'un qui hausse le
ton en général c'est pas quelqu'un
forcément qui veut parler plus fort que
vous c'est quelqu'un qui commence à
avoir le doute dans la conversation et
peut-être même le doute sur le fait
qu'il a encore la main dans la
conversation il veut être sûre de la
reprendre les voitures d'avoir le
pouvoir
donc on peut dire que c'est quelqu'un de
perspicaces mais on pourrait aller plus
loin en disant que c'est quelqu'un qui
ne laisse rien ne lui échappe et
quelqu'un qui va parler un peu plus
lentement qu'il va avoir des fins de
phrases un petit peu traînante qui a un
rythme et une intonation monotone qui
paraît un peu défaitiste un petit peu
dans le découragement vous n'allez pas
lui dire vous êtes défaitiste dans le
découragement et puis vous n'allez rien
faire de cette information là d'une
manière brute par contre vous pouvez
modeler cette information encore une
fois on est sûr que ces personnes là
elle désire des choses donc c'est
quelqu'un qui désirait ardemment quelque
chose il ya assez peu de temps encore et
si on lui rappelle cette information
alors ça va lui rend faire prendre
conscience et on peut même l'amener à
prendre conscience de l'importance que
ce désir avait dans sa vie alors que là
il est un petit peu laissé de côté
quelqu'un de très bruyant de très
exubérant qui bouge beaucoup qui parle
beaucoup qui parlent fort qu'est ce que
c'est d'après vous je vais les chercher
et là vous dites c'est quelqu'un qui va
attirer l'attention sur lui oui pourquoi
pas c'est quelqu'un qui veut prendre la
place oui pourquoi pas mais ça traduit
quoi au fond au fond au fond des choses
ça traduit une frustration c'est
quelqu'un qui est plutôt frustré en
réalité si on voulait lui dire une
vérité faire mouche on pourrait le dire
malgré le fait que tu essayes de faire
bonne figure il ya plein de choses que
tu avais espérer et qui se sont pas
réalisées pour une raison ou pour une
autre mais au fond de toi tu as un petit
peu du mal à vivre
hélas en réaction vous allez avoir
quelqu'un qui pilent les bras qui
baissent un petit peu la tête qui france
est un petit peu les sourcils
bref qui va vous offrir tous les signes
du refus
parce qu'il ne voudra pas admettre cette
phrase parce qu'elle aura trop marché
voilà je pense que vous avez bien saisi
le message de cette deuxième vidéo sur
le gold inc il y en aura une troisième
rassurez-vous en tout cas si vous voulez
dites le moi dans les commentaires vous
pouvez m'en parler et je vais laisser un
petit peu de temps pour vous puissiez
mettre ses conseils la en application
avant de vous faire passer essayer en
tout cas de vous faire passer une
troisième étape là dedans
merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo si
elle vous a plu je vous conseille un
petit col de reading sur ma personne
pour peut-être l'a gratifié d'un petit
pouce en l'air
n'oubliez pas également de vous abonner
à la chaîne avant de partir puisque le
mental blog c'est une vidéo par jour
pendant un an on approche de la moitié
de l'année d'ailleurs et de la moitié
des vidéos donc rendez vous demain à 11h
ciao